you've said that the number one thing
that people come into your office for is
um they want more energy and they don't
want to be quite as fatigued and so
where do you start within your practice
figuring out what the problem is ah
that's a great question um well you know
hippocrates said 2500 years ago that all
disease begins in the gut
and
he didn't have any of the sophisticated
tests we have now uh i don't know how he
knew it
but he was absolutely right and
thanks to work uh some of my work worked
by dr alessio fazzano who's now at
harvard who actually
proved for the first time that
certain
foods certain proteins called lectins he
was focused on gluten
actually
attack the wall of our gut and actually
cause the little things that bind our
gut cells together
tight junctions to break
and to actually cause
spaces between the walls of our gut
where
not only can foreign food particles come
through but also bacteria and as i wrote
in the last book the energy paradox
this creates inflammation
locally in our gut eighty percent of all
of our white cells
literally line uh the intestinal wall
eighty percent
and they're there because that's kind of
our border if you will with the outside
world and normally that border should be
impenetrable
but it's only one cell thick we have
kind of a design flaw and
that
the space the length of our intestines
is actually the same as a tennis court
uh so
you know when we're watching in the
australian open for example
that tennis court is inside of us and
it's only oneself there
so any anything that can kind of get
through that you know thin thin thin
membrane our immune system goes oh my
gosh you know we're under attack
and we need we need all the energy that
you have
to fight this war that's you may not
even feel now most people feel it
by you know fatigue or you know other
believe it or not i see so many
particularly women
with depression and anxiety
and they
don't have a clue unfortunately that
this is actually happening
because of this war that's starting down
in their gut
you guys have taught me so much women
um because you guys thankfully have a
gut feeling and
men and quite frankly most medical
people have pooh-poohed that feeling
that women have
uh luckily i have a wife two daughters
and three female dogs so um
yeah well yeah and luckily i i've
learned that
women have this
sense
that we should pay attention to
for the last 20 years i've been urging
women in particular to please keep
looking for a health care provider
who will take your
complaints seriously and
once people start doing that once i
started saying gee you know that's
are you sure that that's going on i
started looking at the blood work
and i go oh son of a gun you know you're
right um
and let's fix it
um
i mean i'm i can completely attest to
that i
i think that maybe what could be said is
not only to find a practitioner that
takes you seriously and is willing to uh
explore what it is that could be
causing this
um what some may think is imaginary
symptom right but also to
you yourself that person out there to
take your symptoms seriously to take
your intuition seriously probably 2018
i remember thinking to myself like my
body had shifted a little i like gained
a couple of pounds out of nowhere and i
was like man this is so weird and
nothing i did made a dent on it and i
was like
maybe it's just i need to try harder
maybe it's just age maybe it's just that
but my intuition
said my hormones are off i probably
should check them
fast forward now into the end of 2020 i
had another shift like that and i was
like okay this is not okay anymore and
i'm one of those people that does have
great energy and so um it's not as
easily
uh noticed in my world um but then i
finally went in and i had a slew of
things including leaky gut including
dysbiosis including heavy metal toxicity
i mean just tons and tons of stuff
thankfully i felt decent but you know
the ultimate shift for me was i i
finally had cycle issues and then i was
like well i guess i should probably do
something about this um so i think that
yes following that intuition and getting
in touch with the body and trusting that
is a really important thing so um do you
find that food
is the number one culprit
yeah um you know hippocrates also said
you know let food be thy medicine and
medicine be that food he was smart
man i don't know how you figure all this
out but
yeah so that's i guess what made me
famous is that a lot of the
healthy foods that we think are good for
us
actually contain um
mischievous little proteins that are the
defense system of the plant against
being eaten which are called lectins and
lectins
bind to the wall of our gut and they
actually flip a switch that breaks these
tight junctions
and the object of the game for a plant
is not to be eaten
and
to make sure that its babies don't get
it eaten its seeds
and their only defense against being
eaten is to try and make their predator
in that case us
not feel well when we eat certain plants
or plant babies and the object of the
game is a smart animal
if it doesn't feel well or if it's not
thriving or even if it's not reproducing
the animal says you know
every time i eat this plant or this
plant baby i don't feel very well i
think i'll go eat something else
the plant wins the animal wins
everybody's happy
humans as we all know are pretty stupid
and so when we eat things that we have
an intuition or we can feel that
something's not right
we take you know we take prilosec otc or
tums or nexium law we take
antidepressants we take uh aleve advil
and this actually as i write in all my
books makes things worse rather than
better the other thing that i think is
really important that i wrote in the
last book particularly
is
uh
we have
amazing gut dysbiosis now just because
uh of two things number one the
antibiotics that we take
for whatever um
you couldn't believe the number of
people who have been given antibiotics
for coven 19 which
they don't work
it's a it's a virus folks um
number two
antibiotics are fed to almost all of our
conventionally farmed animals and
we use them to make these animals grow
quicker and faster and fatter
um yeah and so yeah
so
when we eat these
animals we actually are eating the
antibiotics that are in their flesh
and so unbeknownst to us
those antibiotics kill off our gut
microbiome so rather than having this
intense beautiful diverse uh
tropical rain forest
of tens of thousands of species of
bacteria in our gut
many of us for instance after a course
of antibiotics
you may be reduced to one or two
bacteria out of ten thousand and it may
take two to three years
to get that
no back say that yeah it's unfortunately
true uh i mean think about it if a
forest burns down and we run in there
and we plant little seedlings
it's going to take 20 or 30 years to get
that forest back and so we've been
really naive
that oh i can take you know some
probiotics the next day and i'll be back
to normal and unfortunately you got to
build this ecosystem in your gut
[Music]